[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so the citizens of Asia as a whole I'm
excited about our relationship over the
next decade
[Music]
[Music]
I wanted to really really focus on in
job so we have our conversation
[Music]
[Music]
basically what I want to get through the
system is people you believe in me you
know because that's how we win that's
how we go fast you know what I'm just
going to do whatever is life and I'm so
confident in what my energy is I know
how I look at it you know just
positivity proceed reject like that
that's positivity and optimism that's
the currency thank you ultimately life
you know you agree to why it was just
yesterday were like sitting there like
opening up a few bottles of stakeout on
where I'm today was a so fun and you're
they just better at this I mean this is
just this is priceless the process to
make the guys you think you
underestimate your value like you like
quick you're out there talking to
entrepreneurs before me and ii see
personal on a daily basis like which in
the last two years the inspiration and
it's the assertion affirmation I guess
commute like no it's Michael Phelps to
like moon on a tech going before you
then I'm going to chewing up scrubbing
through funny dams be quotes before
walking down the streets to go into the
office or before heading into a meeting
it's been powerful for me and it's
really made a difference in the way I
manage my day-to-day I appreciate that
to your point like I think people you
know I'm scared to say how to actually
articulate how much I don't
underestimate it I know exactly what's
happening yeah like amaizing I haven't
started
[Music]
the next meeting they were given to me a
long time ago and I was in my closet and
I was like you know if I wear these
today they feel very like I came from
Hong Kong my Energy's going to be the
same which is to maximize the happiness
and the impact of all the best players
right as you're trying to hire those two
junior video people you just need to get
look for Hustle speed religion and look
at the work the people that know how to
do it are kind of like doing it by
themselves at home like it's an is how I
do I couldn't find anybody for
vaynermedia I just hired people ran them
through it and some work and some did it
cool
[Music]
Asia we just have to dress out dude so
much goodness going on BAM me and
definitely my loved ones live in come
with me there's a lot of things we don't
talk about that make it scary which is
why I don't like the current state of
entrepreneurship in the world because it
seems very party and popular and cool
and it is literally everything but I
started my daily vlog yes I like
attention and I want selfies but much
more because I want people to see how
hard it really is how long every day is
if you really want to be successful and
so I'm scared of everything which
actually ironically means upstairs and
we really grew somebody who has the
ability to understand what is trying to
be accomplished and then know all the
triggers that are underpriced in the
digital landscape to make them happen
I think event marketing is the great
quote ACK of life I really do it's why
all my energies go in that direction
right now like when you think about the
ROI of event marketing that event
marketing should be profitable business
development 2018 we're going we are
going to be the best modern day media
company we're gonna do everything right
you're like like that's what I always
tell the team like it's so frantic like
there's always so much going on but like
sometimes you gotta take a step back and
think about the fact that we little leap
you've got we bought you in January I
got it like I'm seeing it now you know
so that's all I'm just thinking about a
lot of other things but the wine thing
for sure I'm pumped it's real it's gonna
work
[Music]